[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to Friday face
off with me lotty glamorous beauty
editor and amazing makeup artist now
comb hi
so the idea is we have five minutes to
recreate an amazing makeup look and we
don't know what it is yet so how you
feeling about that well let's see I'm
yeah I'm a bit scared to be honest yeah
I don't blame you I know I'm too bad at
doing my makeup so yeah let's see what
we're gonna have to do we got this right
it's the moment of truth we're gonna
find out what today's look is are you
ready I'm ready
do it oh my god oh my god how am I gonna
do this in five minutes it's impossible
that's like at least an hour that's just
mean it's just a mean it's really cool
though I like it I mean I really need
like fishnet tights or something to get
those scales going can the crystals and
everything yeah it's got everything
going on and I'm not sure what order to
do it in what do you think I think we
just go for it just get it on all on
slap it on okay yeah it look good I get
the lashes on as well that's gonna be
quite tricky I'm terrible at printing
lashes on myself okay right let's give
it a go I'm feeling ready let's go for
it yep yep so what have you got what can
you see a little cute Lancome palette
with some blues some like blue shimmery
eyeshadows a little Chanel palette with
like an illuminator okay and I've also
got this Barry M glitter cream palette
which looks quite easy to use I've also
got this makeup obsession eyes shadow
palette which has got all these like
really bright fun colors and eyelashes
as well I'm terrible at putting
eyelashes on myself so this is going
heavy my eyelashes are about half the
size of my face so yeah
okay I'm just gonna try and get this
color I'm really really quickly okay
what are you doing first I'm just
putting eyeshadow on first like as a as
a base that is not what I've chosen to
do no okay right oh no I can't see okay
right four bits left okay
I should actually be quite good at this
because I go as a mermaid every
Halloween I dressed up as a mermaid and
it's not any different costume I do it
you've got an unfair advantage
not really it's never been as crazy as
this if this doesn't work I'm gonna be
lost
oh no punch two minutes gone oh okay put
some pressure on if everything fails go
save us oh my god this is so drinking
okay let me try again right got to move
on okay I can moment of truth oh there's
a massive piece about twice the size of
my eyes you look like you already fought
on your lashes on oh no you haven't seen
I'm only doing one eye okay that's
because I can get it I just look like a
clown to be honest I don't look like a
mermaid
[Music]
okay
oh my god this just looks like a mud
girl AHA but hard to do this under
pressure
I've got lipstick money okay big Revell
three two one you absolutely smashed it
with them now while I really struggle
with these lashes I'm like blinking but
nothing looks so good okay
I really struggled with the tights I
couldn't I couldn't get it over my head
for Low's oh yeah stretch them out right
on but yeah I did it was a bit squishy
and you're like I can actually wear that
look that entire look to a party quite
messy though isn't it sky just slap
thank you so much for watching this
week's Friday face off who do you think
did a better job I just I think it's
gonna be a tie you know I'm not sure I
really love yours I think yours is
really refine I mean I've developed this
habit of only doing half my face but
don't hold it against me thank you so
much for watching and we will see you
next week don't forget to subscribe like
and tag at glam and UK in any of the
Friday face off looks that you recreate
and don't forget to hashtag Friday
things off see you next week
[Music]